honestly you guys i haven't been to
mcdonald's in a really long time the
last time i went to mcdonald's was like
two weeks before i had my daughter so
this is really big for me because i love
mcdonald's
stars they're just like us and kylie
jenner
well she loves her fast food just like
us
i love it in fact she loves it so much
she just dedicated a whole insta story
to her trip through the drive-thru
okay so i would really love a spicy
chicken mcnugget
maybe a 10 piece okay
what else do you recommend for us
tonight
on tuesday night the beauty mogul and
her bestie stasi
hit up their favorite fast food joint
i'm having so much fun
and shared their haul with her 218
million plus followers
i would really love a cinnamon roll
please so let's do two cinnamon rolls
two roll it a two roll two rolls
let's do do you guys still have the fish
fillet
spicy nuggets cinnamon rolls fish fillet
is anyone else suddenly starving i'm
excited about it
kylie went on to rate and review their
order
starting with the fries so i'm going to
show you guys everything we got
fries 10 out of 10. the 23 year old
beauty mogul gave the cinnamon rolls a 9
out of 10
and the spicy chicken nugget okay
well after she removed it from the seat
of her lamborghini
she had this to say the spicy nuggets
aren't very interesting it's safe to say
kylie was living her
best fast food life and she admitted it
had been a minute since she treated
herself
the last time i went to mcdonald's was
like two weeks before i had my daughter
so this is really big for me because i
love mcdonald's
fast forward to 2021 kylie's daughter
stormy whom she shares with travis scott
turned three years old last month so
that's three years without
any spicy chicken nuggets people
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but for stormy's third birthday bash she
did hire raising canes to cater the
event
we're talking chicken tenders french
fries and grilled cheese oh my
thank you and last year kylie opened up
about everything she eats in a day
during a chat with harper's bazaar
there was like a face of
who of hangry that it would be me i
would be the face of hangry
and yes she talked fast food my favorite
cheat meal is probably
i want to say in and out is just
it's just for me when i was pregnant i
had to eat in and out at least once a
week it was a problem
my order either i'll always do a double
cheeseburger with just
special sauce and grilled onions i'll
either get it
protein style or not depending on the
mood fries well done in a coke
you